ah
que jake blake estaba armado y luchó con
fuerza contra la autoridad este es el
argumento con el que la policía de la
ciudad estadounidense de que no se
defiende las actuaciones del oficial que
el 23 de agosto disparó a la espalda del
ciudadano afroamericano luego de que al
parecer se resistiera a ser arrestado el
señor blake rodeó su vehículo abrió la
puerta del lado del conductor y se
inclinó hacia adelante mientras sostenía
su camisa el oficial su [__] skip
disparó su arma de servicio siete veces
contra su espalda durante la
investigación posterior al incidente el
señor blake admitió que tenía un
cuchillo en su poder los agentes de la
dirección de investigación criminal
recuperaron el cuchillo del lado del
conductor del vehículo y no se
encontraron armas adicionales chesqui y
otros agentes que estuvieron presentes
fueron puestos en licencia
administrativa mientras blake afronta su
propio proceso judicial
acusado de haber agredido sexualmente a
su ex pareja y madre de sus tres hijos
de que permaneció esposado hasta el
viernes en la cama del hospital en donde
se recupera sus abogados no descartan
que la próxima semana acuda virtualmente
a una audiencia judicial y se declara
inocente aunque ya fue dejado en
libertad la noticia de que jay culpable
que estaba esposado difundida el jueves
por sus familiares provocó una nueva ola
de protestas anti racismo en todo el
país que continuaron este sábado